hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream for those of you all
who are wondering what this is this is a
series of conversations that we've
started over the last few months it was
I guess catalyzed by Kovac but it's a
way of staying in contact and having
conversations about education what's
going on in the broader world and I'm
super excited for the conversation we're
gonna have in a few minutes with a guest
that when we when we scheduled it we
didn't realize how relevant it would be
to given what's going on in the world
but Before we jump into that
conversation I do want to give a special
shout out to several corporate partners
who stepped up as soon as they realized
that Khan Academy was already running
into deficit preak ovid and that as our
traffic has gone up by a factor of two
two point five 3x and we've tried to
accelerate more programs to support
teachers parents and students and they
stepped up to help us close some of that
gap special thanks to Bank of America
Google org 18t fastly in Novartis and
the many other supporters of Khan
Academy and I just want to make it very
clear you know every donation matters
and we're still running at a deficit so
if you're in a position to do so please
think about making that donation so with
that said I'm eager to introduce our
guest for today a mayor Sam Lockhart Oh
mayor San Jose with a very large city a
major city here in Silicon Valley the
largest city that I am close to I'm here
in Mountain View which is probably about
six or seven miles away from from San
Jose so I'm I consider myself a
constituent of sorts of Mayor Locarno a
mayor Locarno thanks so much for joining
especially considering I'm sure a lot of
things going on in your life right now
yes a challenging moment but I should
say south thank you for all that you and
khanacademy are doing for literally
millions of kids in our country and
throughout the world we're so
appreciative no no and maybe a good
place to start you know when we as I
said when we scheduled this we thought
we were going to talk about Kovan and
maybe the economy and how cities are
thinking about school at you know
education but obviously given what's
going on in the world around George
Floyd and the protests and I guess I
just love your perspective as a mayor of
a major American city how are you
processing it as
and what levers do you think cities or
state or federal government has to kind
of help us navigate this well I think as
you're saying the action really isn't is
is in the cities that is certainly you
know every police department is local
we're probably not going to get much
national leadership on this give them
some of the comments that come out of
the White House and so really mayor's
are mightily challenged along with
police chiefs to really see how we can
meaningfully address the calls for
reform that are out there there's a
righteous cries for change and certainly
they are reflective of what is a decades
if not centuries the old problem we have
had with race and equity in this country
and so you know the underlying
challenges are going to take a lot more
time to solve and I think they're
fundamentally racial and economic but as
we look at this manifestation that is
with the use of force and police
departments and so forth you know this
is an opportunity for a lot of cities I
think to step up in ways to be able to
demonstrate that we were hearing clearly
the cries for change and and to utilize
more innovative approaches that have
been used in the past and give you a
quick example here in San Jose and we're
by no means perfect we are struggling
mightily with this as everyone else is
but we've been really trying to leverage
data as much as possible recording
literally every single police stop every
detention every arrest every questioning
and the demographic information of each
individual and then we make that public
and release it for outside experts to
study one of those reports just came out
last week they analyzed how we're using
force relative to our arrest rates in
each demographic and whether or not our
use of force is getting more severe or
less severe fortunately it's becoming
less severe and and really help us
understand how we can change how we can
improve and so you know I think being
able to be more transparent more
accountable is really a critical first
step and that's something that most of
these can do relatively quickly
obviously much bigger challenges
addressing this fundamental challenge we
have around race in our country which
we could have a very long conversation
about I know right right and just focus
on on this one issue of use of force
which is obviously the the catalyst or
the center of all of this and obviously
there's there's layers to that onion as
you refer to what what do you think I
guess how serious you know how prevalent
is this in police forces what were
mayors and sheriffs thinking about
before this cuz obviously this isn't the
first you know it seems like every few
months there's a case you know some of
them are with the police some of them
are a case of you know some vigilante
doing something that was clear you know
to many of us seem race-based but then
it doesn't seem like justice is served
so what are how can City what were
cities doing before and how do you think
they should approach change in both how
you know that police a citizen
interaction and then also in the
criminal justice system beyond that yeah
I mean what's interesting is I think
that I've been a lot of good changes in
recent years in large cities despite the
fact what we're seeing clearly in the
media is this is still happening way too
often and we know George Floyd
sadly won't be the last and we have seen
this happen so often and we are
desperate
hopefully hoping that this will be the
last but but but we know that there is a
fundamental issue of culture that needs
to change in an awful lot of departments
in terms of racist attitudes around use
of force but I think what is also
particularly challenging as we see the
widespread demonstrations of protests is
how you police a large gathering where
99 percent of the participants are
peacefully expressing the First
Amendment rights and yet you know and
this is true in virtually every city
because I'm having these text exchanges
with all my colleagues and mayor's
throughout the country very progressive
mayors
you know none of them are you know want
to see anything but dramatic change but
they are frustrated because in each city
you have product tours
you know folks who are instant
and provoking to try to get a police
response and maybe it's throwing bottles
or debris
maybe it's blowing up fireworks over the
heads of the officers
maybe it's looting a whole host of
things and the officers are really being
put in an incredibly difficult position
how do you keep everybody safe how do
you protect the city and at the same
time how do you do it constitutionally
and fairly so very difficult issues that
an awful lot of folks are grappling with
I
I am bullish on the ability of an awful
lot of Mayors and police chiefs to step
up to this challenge in the long term
and the short term I think this is much
harder I mean and those are two really
interesting things I would love to
double click and you know for anyone
watching on Facebook or YouTube please
ask questions I see some questions
coming in already I'll get them to the
mayor's as much as we have time for but
on the first question you know you say
there's some culture you know there's
some you know deep racism in certain
pockets of various institutions
including law enforcement how do you
change culture because that feels like
something you can't just you know change
a policy I mean you can do things like
body cams and things like that so you
can monitor a better use of data but how
do you actually change culture what are
mayors sheriff's you know what what can
the police force themselves do what can
the community to do to help change that
culture yeah and that's a really
challenging question because it's not
just police departments look racism
white supremacy this is a history that's
been with us it is in so many
institutions every institution really in
our country it just so happens when it's
in a Police Department the consequences
are deadly and so you know frankly we
all have to be a little more honest with
ourselves about this this reality that
is not just the cop that deserves
scrutiny but it's certainly the cop
because we know they're the ones who are
authorized to use deadly force in our
community what departments like San Jose
are doing I mean starting three or four
years ago yes we were one of the first
cities to deploy body more cameras and
lots of cities are doing that now and so
forth but
I'm really trying to be intentional
around bias-based policing we now have
training in it reek Adam II and
throughout the career every officer here
around bias and hidden bias around the
escalation of violence around what we
call critical incident training which is
really focused on folks having mental
health episodes because we know way too
many of those encounters are resulting
in deadly force and trying to ensure we
can deescalate and get mental health
professionals in there so that it's not
somebody with a badge and a gun who's
having that first encounter of somebody
having I'm in a health episode and in by
the way those are in way too frequently
in communities of color because of lack
of access and mental health resources so
you know there's a lot that needs to be
done those are just three training
modules that we've incorporated now for
every single officer and in the Academy
in there after and it has to be a focus
on continuous improvement because I like
to believe we are one of the most
progressive departments if not the most
in the country and we've got our own
failures and so there has to be an
attitude around and focus of we're not
perfect and we just got to keep pushing
and and what what levers are there I
mean and those all sound like very
powerful ones you know I think one of
the things that was disturbing about the
George Floyd incident tragedy was that
you know not only what did you have the
one officer you know kneeling on it but
then you have several other officers who
kind of stand by and watch and kind of
allow it to happen how does that culture
evolve over time so that it's not oh you
know even even the the more neutral or
the police officers who wouldn't have
done those types of things on their own
but they're they either don't feel you
know don't don't see the space to to
confront their peer or maybe they're
afraid to for some reason I how do you
and I know these are very very hard
questions but but how do you get at the
remove of that type of culture you know
there's are really important questions
but we expect police departments to be
paramilitary organizations that will
follow a chain of authority because when
you put people into situations where
they're under
the risk of serious harm or death as
officers are way too often in our
community we all live in a violent
country and this is what officers are
subjected to that means they have to
follow orders and and follow that chain
of command at the same time we expect
and should expect them to step out of
that chain and correct one another
admonish one another and say hey get off
when it appears that somebody's choking
to death those may be conflicting
tensions and I can't say I'm an expert
in policing but I think we have to be
honest about our expectations of the
police at the same time that we're
certainly demanding more from them and
expecting greater consequence as well ya
know and to your second point I mean I
completely I could imagine many police
officers and sheriff's are are really
struggling with you know where is that
line how do you stop looters but allow
for the peaceful protest you know what
about the in-between situations where
people aren't looting or doing something
illegal but maybe they are very actively
antagonizing hoping for it for a
reaction
what are those conversations like with
your Sheriff with the police force right
now how are they processing it I guess
on both fronts how are they
internalizing some of the change that
needs to happen and then how are they
trying to thread that needle of
protecting the protest and also
protecting property and keeping people
safe well it is challenging and our
police chief here in San Jose or city of
little more than a million people the
tenth largest in the country and so we
have big city challenges and tensions in
very diverse and our police chief Eddie
Garcia came to our city is it as a child
not speaking English so he has a certain
grasp certainly of the the the intensity
of feeling and concern that's coming
from many corners of our community at
the same time I can tell you he is being
absolutely harshly criticized because
we've got officers out there
encountering protesters who are
protesting abusive use of force by the
police at the same time that we are
resorting to tear gas and yes rubber
bullets and I have my own very serious
concern about the use of rubber bullets
for example and
crowd management but that is used widely
and in virtually every big city in this
country and so these are really hard
conversations they take time and they
take an ability to reflect and ability
for folks to have take a breath and
unfortunately that's not this moment
right now we've got a lot of folks
reacting and it's hard to have
meaningful conversations about change at
the same time that folks are reacting to
the minute-to-minute stress right right
now there's some questions about that
from from YouTube ad it's you go this
really question about how do you have
changes to your point you know right now
there's we're in a highly heightened
state emotional state people are angry
you know often you know it's kind of
like they've been seeing patterns over
multiple years now and you know there's
also a sense that for every one you see
how many hundreds might happen that you
don't see that aren't don't get happened
to get captured on a on a on a phone
camera and then for every one of those
how many of those don't end up deadly
but could still end up you know quite
humiliating or dehumanizing and so
Adithya ask you know what hi mayor
Lockhart Oh what do you think is the
best way to voice change in our country
is it protesting petitions
I don't want violence but I do want
effective change and I think Adithya is
kind of voicing what would frankly
almost every American is thinking right
now well you know I hate to tread on
familiar ground and sound a little too
Pollyannish but get out there and
register to vote and get other people to
register vote and you know get folks to
register for the census and get engaged
in the hard change I think look there's
no question that the the demands for
change are righteous coming from
protesters in this city and throughout
the country at the same time the
expectations that we're going to
suddenly move and change major
institutions overnight has never been
the reality it takes hard work in a
democracy and it means people have to
get engaged to the ballot box engaged in
their City Council's
gauged in getting people who are good to
go run for office who have the values
that are consistent with theirs you know
I hate to get too partisan here but you
know we do have a real challenge in
national leadership in this country at
this moment and we can all imagine how
this conversation might go differently
if we had the prior president rather
than this one there's only one way we're
going to change that and that means we
got to get a lot of people registered
because it's by no means of forsaking
conclusion what this election is going
to be and what's your sense of protests
themselves you know this is you know and
you just think about it intellectually
like okay well it's it's show solidarity
it shows a lot of people care about this
but what do you think is going to be the
impact of the protests themselves so
maybe it does activate more people to
vote but but does it have an impact does
it do feet you know you're in City Hall
you're talking to a lot of the players
does it change thinking in your mind
yeah I mean I think it does there's no
question that it's opening eyes in my
conversations with my colleagues mayor's
throughout the country and my own Police
Chief and others that I think people are
understanding and the depth of the pain
in ways that perhaps we didn't before
but let me also be blatantly political
for a moment and coldly calculating I am
very concerned about how this narrative
plays out in perhaps those suburban
communities that may not be as
sympathetic where there are those on one
side essentially use this to demonstrate
why we need more harsh militaristic
approach to law enforcement in this
country to contain the looting and the
violence and all the other ramifications
of having those folks who are out there
provoking that kind of response within
the crowd it's obviously more than 99%
of folks are there for the right reason
it's those 50 or 100 folks that are
creating the huge challenge in every
city and I'm very concerned about the
long term implications of what this
means
for those suburban voters particularly
as we go in this next national election
yeah yeah no it's a complex issue for
sure and you know maybe we go one layer
out because you know when we when we
first scheduled this conversation
obviously we didn't know that this was
going to be the state of affairs in the
world and I think you know kovat is the
the underlying thing and you know one of
the aspects of kovat is its it's kind of
heightened a lot of economic inequality
and to your point a lot of what we're
talking about even with the the the
protests and all of that surrounding it
there is an underlying there's a race
aspect and then mingled with that is
there's kind of an economic aspect of it
how do you think I guess how do mayor's
like yourself think about this issue how
do y'all you know what levers are there
at your disposal for addressing economic
inequality or even educational
inequality or maybe you know issues like
racism generally yeah you know there's
no question at the root of this and you
know we are seeing the issue played out
around use of force in police but at the
root of this is issues of racial equity
and economics and the fact that poverty
in this country is too closely
correlated to race and and I believe
that is the root of much of what we're
grappling with and you know we saw that
lay bare as you said Mike ovid and we
saw the disparities even more impactful
in terms of health outcomes a lot next
populations African American populations
that are dying at higher rates being
infected higher rates I'm trying to see
how we can use not use but find
opportunity in this crisis and by the
crisis now I'm just referring to
pandemic for a moment you know as we
think about the ability to use emergency
orders to move more quickly to mobilize
for example we've got a huge
homelessness challenge here as every
city does in California throughout the
West Coast and so we're using some of
the emergency orders to be able to
streamline construction of prefabricated
modular housing at a relatively low cost
maybe 30 $40,000 per unit where it
normally costs 700,000
to build a unit in a typical apartment
building and we'll be able to build some
of these projects now that we've got
underway in four weeks it or no they
take four years I'm gonna get about 500
homeless people how is this way you know
this is how we can find an opportunity
in this crisis so we think about the
digital divide that is so impactful
particularly we want all the important
work that Khan Academy is doing right
now again using the the ability to push
red tape out of the way to be able to
more rapidly deploy free Wi-Fi right now
we've got a lot of interesting projects
going on a very large school district on
East part of our city where we have very
high population of families without
internet access right here in the heart
of Silicon Valley sadly and we just
connected one community around James
Lake High School 6,000 families with
free Wi-Fi and a few weeks we'll be able
to do that with another community around
another high school in East San Jose and
we're now gonna do it with three or four
more and partnership with that school
district we're finding the resources
using a little bit of the federal money
that's been released and most
importantly getting the red tape out of
the way and moving much faster so I'm
hoping to be able to leverage this
moment to be able to move more rapidly
because we know for example every child
is now learning online
khadi with Khan Academy because they
have connectivity is also have as a
parent who's able to find a job online
and as a grandparent is able to get
health information so we know this is
critical these are the kinds of
disparities we have to attack
aggressively and and how do you think
you know is is co vyd do you see is this
is gonna I mean that I think in some
dimensions it's obviously going to make
things worse it's disproportionately
folks who work in service industries
things like that how are you I guess in
the short term you know I know you have
this committee and that you know that
I've been participating in many other
leaders in the area around how do you
think we do this you know with the
restaurants struggling and obviously
that has following consequences with all
of the people who work and supply the
restaurants
how should a city think about getting
through kovat and then I guess beyond
yeah and in this recovery roundtable
that we create here in Silicon Valley
and thinks self being a part of this you
know we're really focusing on
how we can most importantly get a lot of
folks back to work who may not be
getting back to work otherwise for a
year or two based on for example if
they're in the hotel industry that's
give me a long time for that that
industry comes back and so we know
there's a lot of low-wage workers there
who critically need skills Khan Academy
can help how does that we know they are
now and we want to use whatever tools we
can to help folks get Rhys killed and
back working again and you know part of
this again will be around funding the
opportunity in crisis as we think about
the many businesses that can't do
business the same way because of social
distancing they've got a small business
and they can't get customers in and out
the door at nearly fast enough rate you
know we announced a an alfresco
initiative to see how we can get
commerce to happen outside in a city
with 300 days of Sun a year so certainly
more outside seating with restaurants
but getting yoga studios outside and
getting retail outside in a way filling
up sidewalks and closing lanes of
streets to be able to move our activity
outside in a way that may actually be
lasting and maybe something that's
welcoming to folks who increasingly are
thinking about cities in different ways
and and that maybe we really want a city
that is more pedestrian oriented and
less dominated by no I love that last
point and I do hope it's more permeated
actually I think even schools outside
it's something that I've always talked
about especially in out here in
California but you mentioned 300 days
and I think even getting wet a little
bit on the cold and rainy days does
something for your character so I think
there's a there's something to that I
although I haven't heard people talk
about schools outside yet but I'll just
I'll just seed you I think that'll be
great for the kids even if we weren't
trying to socially distance so your more
questions here this is you know it's
going back to the topic where we started
but I think it's an interesting one from
Facebook Carol Smith capper asks just
wondering how you identify candidates
for the police department to keep
racists and people who want to join for
the sense of power it gives them it's
their psychological testing that is done
what about as they progress in their
careers and I'll just add a little bit
too
question which is you know this exactly
obviously this was in Minneapolis not
San Jose and I know you're not the
police chief but you know this was a
situation where there was multiple
complaints against this officer over the
years and so why did not other officers
there you know is it that same cultural
problem so yeah I'd love you know
anything you know about to answer
Carol's question yeah a great question
so as you can imagine super hard discern
who's a racist and who's not know when
they're signing up for any job and there
is psychological testing that's done in
our department as expected most other
big city departments as part of the
screening when folks are going through
the process and it's a very long process
I can tell you typically we have
fourteen fifteen hundred people apply to
be part of a police academy and about
thirty five or forty actually get into
the academy so we're talking about a
very low acceptance rate and there's a
lot of screening now that being said
well I think the best thing police
departments can do since we're not as
human beings able to discern Malcolm
Gladwell actually just wrote a book
about this recently we're not very good
at discerning what strangers really
think what they're not telling us so so
it's really about having a really
effective system for identifying the
yellow and red flags
what is the conduct that's problematic
both with complaints and what people are
seeing within the department so that the
internal affairs offices are really
clearly attuned to who is a challenge
who needs some training who needs some
really clear direction and who needs to
get out quick
and what is a real challenge I think in
big cities throughout the country and
certainly in California is we have this
very erotic system for actually meeting
out discipline and firing officers
because let's face it police unions are
very powerful in every city in every big
state and in California we have what's
called a piece officers Bill of Rights
we have contracts that are signed each
city that make it very difficult to
immediately take action we had an
incident very recently
officer who was involved in the
demonstrations who is engaged in the
area was clearly improper and folks are
calling on me to fire him and I
literally have no authority to fire the
officer now I'm not saying that's what
is deserved in this case I think you
know we need to understand investigate
what happened clearly discipline is
required but I don't have any authority
and in fact even the police chief can't
move at that pace because of the way is
restricted by the contract and by state
law so to get better accountability we
mean some real changes in those legal
structures and again doesn't happen
overnight but it's got to start
happening now you have a sense that
especially with recent incidents that
that might change because obviously you
know the union is there to represent the
interests of its members and obviously
these types of things that happen the
people obviously the the people who are
at the receiving end of the brutality
they suffer but also other good police
officers suffer incredibly their job
becomes that much harder they get
exposed to more anger people will trust
them less due sense that pressure from
within the police force and within the
unions to say hey look we've got to take
out the these actors so that we all of
our jobs are going to be better well I
can say that look nobody hates a bad cop
more than a good cop and and I think I
really believe that based on my
conversations I used to be a criminal
prosecutor and prosecuted sexual assault
crimes and had great relationships with
a lot of officers and I could tell you
they despised hearing this stuff and
seeing this stuff that being said I
think there are very I'll use the word
against erotic political structures in
place that need change and you know I
had this conversation of the governor a
lot of Mayors just a couple days ago and
there was a lot of pent up interest
among mayor's to see this change it's
it's going to take a lot of pushing and
again this is why I say people need to
register look they and you getting
engaged their sleeves because this stuff
isn't simple and that doesn't happen you
don't get simple solutions to tough
problems like this it takes a lot of
pushing no well well that's super
helpful and and and mayor la carta
thanks so much I know you know given the
circumstance
thanks for even you know continuing to
take this I could imagine your life as
you you were telling me right before
though I don't think you slept much the
last couple of days so I really
appreciate taking the time out for
myself and this community for us to
learn about this if you have any other
you know kind of parting words happy to
share them well thanks so thank you for
the great work that you and your
partner's do and you know I think we're
understanding certainly as a result of
kovat thorough of Khan Academy and
distance learning is so critically vital
right now and we know this is going to
be the future so thank you for what
you're doing please continue to support
Khan Academy if you're out there and we
look forward to work together that to
see how we can really solve an awful lot
of our serious challenges around equity
and race and injustice in our in our
community through education
well thank thanks once again for joining
it couldn't it I think I learned a lot
and I think there's some nuance and what
you said that we're not hearing and you
know the broader media right now so
thank you so much Mary Lou Carter so so
thanks everyone for joining hopefully
you found that as as interesting as I
did you know this is one of those
situations where I am just I am NOT an
expert in any of this but you know at
Khan Academy we try to pride ourselves
in being curious and this is going to be
a learning process for all of us of how
do we process all of this information
and what are the steps that we can
collectively take put one foot in front
of the other so that we can hopefully
move society forward so thanks everyone
for joining and we will continue
tomorrow tomorrow will just be your
standard ask me anything and then I look
forward to having more guests like like
Mayor lekar DOE and the in the weeks to
come
thanks everyone for joining
you